Вітаю вас, друзі.
Мене звуть Юрій, я викладач математики
«Креативної Міжнародної Дитячої Школи».
Сьогодні у нас урок математики в 6 класі.
Побудова паралельних та перпендикулярних
прямих за допомогою косинця та лінійки.
Для початку давайте згадаємо, що
таке паралельні та перпендикулярні прямі?
Нагадаю.
Паралельні прямі – це дві прямі
на площині, які не перетинаються.
У них нема спільних точок.
Перпендикулярні прямі – це прямі,
які при перетині утворюють
кут 90 градусів, тобто прямий кут.
Насправді там утворюється 4 прямих кути.
Отже давайте сьогодні за
допомогою таких інструментів,
як косинець – це такий собі
макет прямокутного трикутника
та лінійки навчимося будувати чітко
перпендикулярні та паралельні прямі.
Увага на дошку.
Перша задача виглядає так.
Нехай у нас є довільна пряма а.
Я зараз пряму позначу
маленькою буквою та довільна
точка, яка належить цій
прямій, нехай це точка В.
Напишу нижче, згадайте
точка В належить прямій а.
Моя задача зараз побудувати
пряму, яка буде перпендикулярна
прямій а і яка буде
проходити через точку В.
Для розв’язання цієї задачі нам
знадобиться такий прилад, як косинець.
Косинець я повинен
приставити до нашої прямої таким
чином, щоб його нижня частинка
співпадала с самою прямою.
Ось таким чином.
Потім пере двинути цей
косинець вздовж прямої таким
чином, щоб точка співпадала
з прямим кутом косинця.
Далі нам залишається провести
лише пряму, яка є перпендикулярною.
Потім я відкладаю косинець, беру лінійку
і дану сторону продовжую до прямої.
У нас вийшла пряма b,
яка буде перпендикулярна
прямій а, яка проходить через точку В.
Давайте це запишемо, а
значок перпендикулярності b.
Читають а перпендикулярно до b.
Перейдемо до наступного типу задач.
Наступна задача.
Нехай у нас є довільна пряма
а і є точка, яка знаходиться
поза прямою, тобто тне
належить їй, нехай це точка В.
Наша задача зараз побудувати
пряму перпендикулярну прямій а,
яка буде проходити саме через точку В.
Давайте це зробимо.
Отже, знову ж таки нам
знадобиться косинець.
Аналогічним чином ми
приставляємо косинець щоб
його нижня частина
співпадала з нашою прямою
і рухаємо його таким чином, щоб друга
частинка косинця співпадала з точкою В.
Далі проводимо пряму.
У нас утворився прямий кут 90 градусів.
Далі продовжимо нашу
пряму за допомогою лінійки.
Утворилася нова пряма,
нехай вона буде прямою b .
Позначимо, що а перпендикулярна до b.
В свою чергу точка В належить цій прямій.
Давайте це теж запишемо,
що точка В належить прямій b.
Побудовано, перейдемо до
розв'язування деяких інших задач.
Увага на дошку.
Поясню, що таке шаблон кута 15 градусів.
За допомогою транспортира я
можу позначити лише кут 15 градусів,
інші кути я не можу позначити
за допомогою транспортира.
Давайте спробуємо розв’язати цю задачу.
Перпендикулярні прямі –
це прямі, які перетинаються
під прямим кутом, тобто
утворюють кут 90 градусів.
У нас є шаблон 15 градусів.
Давайте подумаємо,
а скільки ж разів у кут
90 градусів вміщається
кути по 15 градусів?
Якщо поділити 90 на 15
очевидно, що в прямому
куті рівно 6 маленьких
кутів по 15 градусів.
Це нам допоможе для побудови
перпендикулярних прямих.
Давайте для початку просто
побудуємо шаблон 15 градусів.
Використовую для цього транспортир.
Проводжу довільну пряму, з’єдную
нижню частинку транспортира
з цією прямою і відкладаю
шаблонний кут 15 градусів.
Ставлю тут точечку, прибираю транспортир
і з’єдную нашу точку з вершиною кута.
Ось я побудував шаблон кута 15 градусів.
Далі для побудови прямого кута я повинен
шість разів відкласти даний шаблон.
Давайте це зробимо.
Користуючись транспортиром,
я зараз буду будувати
наступний кут, градусна
міра якого 15 градусів.
Для цього я повинен з’єднати
нижню частинку транспортира вже з
верхньою частиною нашого
першого шаблонного кута 15 градусів.
Знову знаходжу позначку
15 градусів, ставлю точку і
з’єдную вершину нашого кута
з поставленою раніше точкою.
Скажіть, будь ласка, скільки вже разом ці
два кути будуть, точніше їх градусна міра?
Разом вони вже будуть
утворювати 30 градусів.
Для побудови прямого кута
мені залишається відкласти
15 градусів, тобто шаблон
15 градусів, ще 4 рази.
Отже, відклавши шаблон
15 градусів 6 разів, разом в
сумі вони дають кут,
градусна міра якого 90 градусів.
Давайте перевіримо за
допомогою транспортира.
Прикладаємо нижню частинку нашого
транспортира з нижньою частинкою
першого кута і дивимось, так, дійсно,
у нас вийшов прямий кут 90 градусів.
Надалі, щоб побудувати
перпендикулярні прямі,
я продовжу першу побудовану
побудовану сторону кута,
Та останню сторону побудованого кута.
Відповідно в мене вийшло дві прямі,
пряма а і пряма b, які між
собою перпендикулярні.
Давайте це запишемо.
Задачу розв’язано, перейдемо до наступної.
Наступна задача.
Це задача трошки складніша.
Давайте подумаємо як ми її можемо зробити.
Градусна міра прямого
кута дорівнює 90 градусів.
Нам потрібно побудувати кут 12 градусів.
Якщо ми 5 разів відкладемо шаблон кута 17
градусів, 5 помножити
на 17 буде дорівнювати 85.
Якщо ми 6 разів
відкладемо кут 17 градусів, 6
помножити на 17 буде
дорівнювати 102 градуси.
Тобто коли ми 5 разів
відкладаємо кут 17 градусів,
то в нас не вистачає 5
градусів до прямого кута.
Коли ми відкладаємо
17 градусів 6 разів, в нас
навпаки, перебір якраз 12
градусів від прямого кута.
Тобто якщо ми із однієї із
сторін прямого кута 6 разів
відкладемо шаблон 17 градусів
у нас вийде перебір 12 градусів.
Давайте це зробимо.
Для початку побудуємо прямий кут.
Для побудови прямого кута мені знадобиться
косинець і лінійка або просто транспортир.
Зараз я побудую прямий кут
за допомогою транспортира.
Відкладаю довільну пряму і відразу
відмічаю точку, яка дорівнює 90 градусів.
Будую прямий кут.
З’єдную дану точку з
нижньою стороною нашого кута.
Я побудував зараз прямий кут.
Починаю від нижньої сторони прямого кута
відкладати 6 разів шаблон 17 градусів.
Зроблю це іншим маркером.
Нагадую, як це робиться.
Нижню сторону кута суміщаю з
нижньою частинкою транспортира.
Відкладаю кут 17 градусів.
З’єдную вершину кута з цією точкою.
Отже, я відклав від нижньої сторони
кута один раз 17 градусів цей шаблончик.
Надалі я повторю таку
процедуру ще 5 разів, але щоразу я
буду відкладати наступний
шаблон від вже побудованого кута.
Давайте це проробимо.
Шукаю 17 градусів.
Отже, від нижньої сторони кута я
відклав 6 разів шаблон кута 17 градусів.
Ось це в мене 17 градусів і
наступні кути теж по 17 градусів.
Разом в сумі вони дають 102 градуси.
Але, увага, чорний кут і його
градусна міра 90 градусів.
Якщо я відніму від 102 градусів 90
градусів в мене вийде якраз 12 градусів,
тобто той кут, який в мене залишився
ліворуч від другої сторони прямого кута.
Давайте його і позначимо.
Адже 102 градуси мінус 90
градусів буде якраз 12 градусів.
Задачу розв’язано.
Для розв’язання наступної
задачі нам необхідно
зрозуміти, як будувати паралельні прямі.
Увага на дошку.
Зараз я проведу довільну пряму, пряму а.
Мені якимось чином потрібно чітко
побудувати пряму паралельну до цієї.
Що для цього треба зробити?
Для початку позначу довільну
точку, нехай це буде А, на цій прямій.
Проведу перпендикулярну пряму до прямої а.
Нагадаю як це робиться.
Робиться це за допомогою косинця.
Приставляю нижню частинку
косинця так, щоб точка
співпадала з вершиною
прямого кута косинця.
Проводжу перпендикулярну пряму.
Далі беру знов довільну точку на
вже отриманій перпендикулярній прямій.
Нехай це буде точка В.
І аналогічним чином
проводжу вже перпендикулярну
пряму до прямої, яка утворилася до цього.
Для цього косинець, його нижню частину
суміщай таким чином, щоб ця точка В
і вершина прямого кута косинця співпадали.
Проводжу пряму, яка
буде перпендикулярна до
нашої прямої b, до речі,
давайте позначимо її.
У нас утворилась третя пряма с,
давайте її продовжимо до прямої.
Третя пряма с, вона і
буде паралельна прямій а.
Це випливає з наслідку
про перпендикулярні прямі.
Якщо пряма а і пряма b між собою
перпендикулярні, пряма b і пряма с
між собою перпендикулярні, то
пряма а і пряма с між собою паралельні.
Позначимо прямі кути, що в нас
утворилися і те, що в нас вийшло.
Пряма а паралельна прямій с.
Отже, перейдемо до наступної задачі.
Увага на екран.
Перейдемо до розв’язання.
Для початку я повинен
зобразити дві паралельні прямі.
Досить швидко нагадаю як це робиться.
Проводжу довільну пряму.
На цій прямій позначаю
довільну точку, через
яку я повинен провести
перпендикулярну пряму.
За допомогою косинця роблю це.
Проводжу перпендикулярну пряму.
Далі на вже перпендикулярній
прямій я ставлю
довільну точку і вже до цієї
перпендикулярної прямої,
через цю точку я будую третю пряму,
яка буде перпендикулярна до попередньої.
Роблю це таким чином, продовжую до прямої.
Отже, початкова пряма а і пряма
с будуть між собою паралельні.
Пряма b в нас була додаткова пряма, яка
допомогла нам побудувати
ці дві паралельні прямі.
Зараз я можу витерти цю пряму,
вона нам більше не потрібна.
Далі в умові задачі нас просять,
щоб дві інші прямі були не паралельні.
Це робиться досить просто.
Будую дві інші прямі,
наприклад таку і таку.
Увага у нас утворився
чотирикутник, нехай точка перетину
А, точка перетину В, точка
перетину С та точка перетину D.
Чотирикутник АВСD у якого ВС паралельно
АD, а АВ і СD між собою не паралельні.
Перейдемо до другого пункту цієї задачі.
Давайте зобразимо це на малюнку.
Спочатку будую першу
пару паралельних прямих.
Будую довільну пряму, ставлю точку.
Будую перпендикулярну пряму,
на ній ставлю теж довільну точку.
І вже будую третю перпендикулярну
пряму до другої прямої.
Продовжую до прямої.
Таким чином у мене утворилась
перша пара паралельних прямих.
Додаткову пряму, яка у нас була я приберу.
Пряма а паралельна прямій b.
Давайте запушу це.
Далі мені потрібно намалювати
ще одну пару паралельних
прямих, які не будуть
паралельні цим прямим.
Тобто я повинен провести довільну
пряму, нехай це буде пряма с.
До прямої с я повинен
побудувати паралельну пряму.
Роблю аналогічні дії.
Ставлю довільну точку на цій
прямій і будую перпендикулярну пряму.
На перпендикулярній
прямій я ставлю, знову ж таки,
ще одну довільну точку,
нехай вона буде у нас тут.
І вже до цієї прямої будую третю
пряму, перпендикулярну до попередньої.
Продовжую до прямої.
Додаткову пряму, яку я використовував для
побудови другої пари
паралельних прями я приберу.
Отже, в мене вийшла ще
одна пара паралельних прямих.
Нехай це пряма с та нова наша пряма d.
Пряма с паралельна прямій d.
У нас утворився чотирикутник - KLMN
у якого дві сторони паралельні і
дві інші теж між собою паралельні.
Сьогодні на уроці ми з вами
познайомились з побудовою паралельних
та перпендикулярних прямих
за допомогою косинця та лінійки.
Це допоможе вам в кращому освоєнні
геометрії, яка у вас почнеться з 7 класу.
До зустрічі на наступних уроках.